a lot of people have
mistakenly taken my kind interactions
for weakness if you're a vendor who
thinks I'm weak in negotiating and I at
the last minute buy all the product from
someone else instead of you you very
quickly realized you were mistaken and
so people will realize that through
action who you are I'm more fascinated
by the person that
thinks invoking fear into people or
seemingly not being kind is a good
strategy when they're incapable to
execute with action on the back end then
you just become a barking dog that
everybody realizes will never bite and
then you become a doormat and people
walk all over you and you've lost twice